[Musique]
c'est voilà donc on a vécu tellement de
choses et je sais que je lui dois je le
dois énormément aussi dans ma carrière
est-ce que ça a pu vous contrarier vous
avez assez parfois quand vous considère
bah c'était un peu fédéral le prodige
vous le besogneux ouais mais ça c'est la
réalité ça s'est jamais été un problème
c'est sûr que
comme dans toute situation comme dans la
vie en général il y a du positif et du
négatif tout simplement dans cette
dans cette situation il y a eu
énormément de positif parce que j'ai
pris énormément et j'ai j'ai grandi et
je me suis amélioré grâce à lui sur
énormément de points il m'a énormément
aidé sur ma carrière grâce à lui j'ai
gagné les Jeux Olympiques et la Coupe
Davis c'est deux de mes plus gros titres
de ma carrière donc il y a énormément de
positif après c'est sûr que le fait
d'arriver
derrière lui
surtout en Suisse peu importe les
résultats que je pouvais avoir de toute
façon ce sera ça allait toujours être à
des années-lumière de lui de toute façon
personne n'arrivera à faire ce qu'il a
fait en tout cas pas en Suisse et moi ce
que je fais je le fais du mieux possible
mais il faut pouvoir apprécier aussi ce
genre de carrière